well it's a great pleasure to be able to
join in this tribute to clyde
who became a good friend as well as a
good colleague over the years
he was a one-off nobody quite liked
clyde
his enthusiasm and energy and joy of eve
will be
missed by all of us
and in a very real sense he injected
productive energy
into the cbd program
he was a very good scientist
but he was working with
a scintillating collection
of amazing
international stars
what he had particularly was a strategic
vision to pull the group together
now to be easy to assume
that inevitably the program will be the
weaker
as a result of his absence
and of course we will miss the fun and
excitement that he provided but to focus
on what we will miss
is to entirely overlook
the tremendous contributions he made
that will continue to live on
and indeed continue to grow because they
have now such a firm basis
what i would like to do
is to mention briefly what i see as his
major contributions
before going on to note the challenges
that remain
i label these challenges
rather than unanswered questions
because clyde would never have been
dismayed
by the extent to which so much remains
unknown
indeed
instead as always with his
insatiable curiosity he would be looking
for ways to meet those challenges
his lasting legacy should be the
determination
given to us to solve the problems
provided by those challenges
that is a cbd
determination
that will i'm sure bring rich rewards
his achievements well the first i think
was to use clyde's phrase the
recognition of the importance of the
biological embedding of experiences
he was not the first to identify the
phenomenon that goes back over half a
century but he was one of the first to
put it at the very top of the agenda
at a time when so many psychosocial
researchers remained adamantly
uninterested in biology
for clyde following on biologists such
as robert hind
to regard biology and the environment as
entirely separate was a complete
nonsense
second he emphasized the crucial
importance of identifying the mechanisms
that mediated the environmental impact
on the biology
it would be only a slight exaggeration
to say that he had a conversion from a
geographical
epidemiologist
to an epigenetic
evangelist epigenetics constituting as
we have heard the chemical changes that
influence gene expression
but to describe clyde's involvement in
epigenetics as a conversion
is nevertheless an exaggeration
because clyde appreciated that
epigenetics
constituted just one of many
possible biological mediators of
environmental effects
meaning the mechanisms involved in their
effects
everyone's genes are as we have heard
fixed from the outset
but their functional effects
only
come about when the genes are expressed
in the tissues
epigenetics concerns the features
outside of the genes themselves
that shape the influence of the genes
the tasks are to delineate the several
interacting processes involved and clyde
would have played a key role in meeting
that challenge
third
building on his background as an
epidemiologist
he emphasized the narrowness of an
exclusive focus on individual
causes only at an individual level
why was it
that some
population groups had rates of crime
family breakdown poverty and
unemployment so much higher than others
living in nearby areas
was this just because birds of a feather
flocked together or were the social
forces of some kind
at work
what was striking too
that clyde was insistent that such
population approaches had to include
health and illness indices
that implied of course that the
solutions too might be best applied to
populations
and not just to high-risk individuals
finally although not himself primarily a
trialist or evaluator of interventions
he was certainly not an ivory tower
academic
for him it mattered greatly that
knowledge be put to good purposes
whether in terms of policy prevention or
intervention once more a key cfar goal
so
what are the challenges to be faced
first if all environments tend to have
epigenetic effects
or hpa effects or structural brain
changes
is there a degree of mildness below
which there are few if any epigenetic
changes
does the type of environment matter
are acute stress is the same as chronic
adversities the evidence certainly
indicates that the hpaf hpa effects are
not the same for the two but does that
also apply to the epigenetics
do pleasurable positive experiences
have the same biological effects as
unpleasant abusive ones
can the pattern of epigenetic changes
differentiate abuse from neglect
and both of those from social
disadvantage
can the biological changes differentiate
between
sensitivity and stealing or
strengthening effects
we know that some challenges enable
individuals
to come through stronger and less
vulnerable than before
equally however
in other individuals or other
circumstances
they become sensitized so that they
exhibit
increased susceptibility to later
stresses
is this difference reflected
in a different biology
most fundamentally do we have sensitive
and discriminating measures of the
relevant environmental features
can the biology be informative
on the likely health effects
it's all very well
to identify the stress physiology but
what connection does this have
with either physical or mental ill
health
one set
of key features that differentiates
responses
to the environment are the polymorphic
genetic markers that is the genetic
features that determine individual
differences
but what are the mediating biological
processes
do they as some suggested involve
epigenetic changes
also
do they deal just with responses to
adverse environments or rather do they
involve responsivity to both good and
bad environments
it seems evolutionary impossible
that there would be genes concerned only
with damaging environments
perhaps the mechanism involved is a
general responsivity to all environments
if that proved to be the case there
would be important implications for
treatment and prevention
there are other challenges but there's
time to mention only one
more in the domain of biomarkers it is
common to find biological markers or
indices
that differentiate groups
in terms of health outcomes
but it's rare indeed to find markers
that are sufficiently reliable and
sufficiently valid
to be of use for differentiating
individuals who will or will not develop
disorders
can those be developed to a point when
they are useful at an individual level
well
it would have been great of course if
clyde was still here to help
with answering these questions because
undoubtedly he would
and
his creative imagination
and looking forward would have been a
help
much remains to be done but helped by
clyde's vision
energy and collaborative endeavors his
legacy will give cbd
the strength and creative ideas to
achieve what he was aiming for
you